[Musique]
oui Maroni aujourd'hui je suis dans
l'Ouest à quelques mètres du lagon et je
vais te présenter le dispositif que l'on
appelle
Atlet
de temps libre c'est un dispositif
proposé par la CAF pour permettre aux
familles de passer des vacances ensemble
et bien justement allons voir comment ça
se passe
si vous aussi l'aide de temps libre vous
intéresse alors suivez-moi
les aidants libres sont destinés aux
familles ayant au moins un enfant à
charge et disposant de ressources
limitées ces aides permettent de partir
en vacances en famille parmi les 6
centres de vacances existant à la
Réunion il y a le village corail à
Saint-Gilles-les-Bains allons voir ça
alors dites-nous comment se passe un peu
les vacances alors il y a la piscine il
y a intérêt pétanque de jeu pas la plage
et après ben il y a le football il y a
plein d'activités en fait il y a aussi
activité manuelle de quoi faire pour les
petits et les grands voilà et on
connaissent important pour vous pour
créer les liens que la famille avec mes
enfants surtout parce que m'avait perdu
un petit peu et là franchement la
recette est bien on se retrouve et
racontez-nous un peu comment sont passés
les démarches
il y a plus de six mois de ça et ma
retire le dossier mais après m'a fait
par voie postale mais après
s'autoriser un peu de repos décompressé
passer des journées complètes avec les
enfants des moments simples qui
permettent de vacanciers de renouer le
temps d'un séjour avec l'essentiel de la
vie de famille
alors dites-nous comment fait-on pour
passer des vacances ici alors pour venir
en vacances en famille au village corail
il faut bénéficier de la TL donc l'aide
de temps libre c'est une aide qui est
mise en place par la CAF de la Réunion
pour que les familles puissent profiter
des centres de vacances comme ici et
c'était délimiter à 80% prise en charge
pour cela il faut être un locataire de
la caisse de la caution familiale de la
Réunion avoir au moins un enfant à
charge inconscient familial inférieur à
700 euros et faire un minimum de trois
nuités pour un séjour ici au village
alors du coup qui doit-on contacter
alors avant toute chose les vacances ça
se prépare donc il faut nous envoyer le
formulaire environ 6 mois à l'avance
nous il faut nous contacter directement
nos équipes se chargeront de traiter les
dossiers dans les meilleurs délais merci
Martine merci à vous
grâce à l'aide de temps libre avoir des
moments de vacances devient plus facile
les sites comme celui-ci permettent aux
familles de s'évader pour quelques jours
une manière de rompre avec le quotidien
au grand bonheur des enfants mais aussi
des parents
si vous souhaitez en savoir davantage
sur l'aide au temps libre n'hésitez pas
les coordonnées s'affichent en ce moment
même sur votre écran le département des
générations c'est déjà fini si vous
voulez revoir cet épisode ainsi que les
précédents rendez-vous sur nos sites et
nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je vous
retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine nous allons
découvrir les pattes de Saint-Pierre un
établissement financier PAL ARS et le
département adapté pour accueillir des
personnes âgées dépendantes et moins
dépendantes ou toutes les autres
personnes de la situation le nécessite
[Musique]